un moment donné c'est fatigant donc on
prend un peu plus de temps entre les
tensions ont déjà fait craquer sur la
place
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un procès au dépanneur ce week-end qui
était comme un fils sur son score plus
de 4 millions samedi soir nous voilà
c'est vrai qu'on cherche tout le temps
des poux dans la tête
mais bon je touche ou un chocolat c'est
la france a pris ses marques et oui je
rebondissais sur votre imitation d'avant
et je vais dire que parler honnêtement
est-ce que vous entraîner pour des
vacances se pose la bonne question
coquine on joue vraiment j'ai une
question coquine la partie c'est toute
la question
[Applaudissements]
même plus sûr sur france ô combien ont
déjà fait crac crac badaboum
[Rires]
combien ont déjà fait crac crac badaboum
deux fois dont la même eu un vrai
sondage 50% des personnes avec la même
personne
alors allez voir ce que ça arrive à 35
65 5 aux accords castaldi ou perd des
impôts là
[Applaudissements]
c'était 89 pour cela